a fridge is a fridge is a fridge but not
always from organized and labeled to the
exotic to the mundane they run the gamut
the book inside chefs fridges gives a
peek inside the home refrigerators of
some of Europe's top chefs it's an
almost intimate look behind the scenes
of haute cuisine either they were kind
of a maniac and really clean really
organized and that was always a
reflection on who they were as a chef of
the restaurant or they were kind of you
know kind of messy fly by the seat of
their pants you know the menu changes
every day
my you know make up something crazy in
the middle of the service well those
chefs had kind of a messy fridge or they
were missing some essential things they
may have had a bit too much booze or
there was something that was a bit off
for the corner Paris the city of romance
and good food it's also home to the
creative duo behind inside chefs fridges
us food photographer Carrie Solomon and
Adrian more from Britain he's a
concierge in a luxury Paris hotel and
also writes for a food blog and magazine
their book profiles 40 chefs from across
Europe including many who run
award-winning kitchens both obsessed
with restaurants and the we tried to
book together the idea came to me in my
kitchen barefoot with probably a
hangover I was looking at my fridge and
I had the idea I mean it was the idea
that brought everything together one of
the chefs is Daniel Achilles a native of
Dresden he now runs Berlin's Weinstock
restaurant which is known for
contemporary German cuisine that
features regional products he's already
received two Michelin stars and last
year he was named Germany's chef of the
year but his refrigerator at home is
surprisingly ordinary regular food
including hot dogs and soy sauce I made
it as tag isn't a cushioned shifts at
the end of the day star chef sir
whatever you want to call them are just
regular people cancel my dimension oh
and that one's carved in our place it's
my wife who does the shopping this vegan
so our refrigerator looks like our
neighbors or your basic regular guys
kolega Han Heinz moolah Daniel Achilles
his wife and son live near the
restaurant at his restaurant he's always
coming up with new ideas and creations
but at home simplicity reigns even a
michelin-starred chef needs to relax and
rest his palate
spy Mia loss during the week meals at
home are quick what we're doing isn't
really cooking it's just making sure
we're all fed so I phone walk from
mountains of nama douche China is also a
two star chef who runs the restaurant
Hessian in southern Germany she also
gave the authors a look at her private
kitchen for Steiner cooking at home is
mainly about sharing time with her
family her refrigerator is down to earth
with plenty of fresh vegetables and
regional products we think her daughter
cooks with her lungs she had oh she had
a really nice family family filed or
fridge you could see it with someone who
had you know children around to cook for
the authors wanted to create a cookbook
not just a collection of pretty pictures
they asked each of the profiled chefs to
develop two recipes especially for the
book but that wasn't always easy most of
the big coffee table books out there by
big chefs the recipes are absolutely
impossible to do I mean not own you
cannot find the products I mean you
don't have to take me to do it so for us
the recipes had to be simple and some of
the chef's it took us months for them to
scale down their recipe to something was
extremely complex or something where
they would substitute things and make it
easy for the home cook inside chefs
fridges and to demystify out cuisine it
turns out that even celebrity chefs are
much like the rest of us and their
refrigerators are pretty ordinary to